e siamo così giunti con cotanta barba e
baffi incolti agli infiltrati in dieci
ragazzi che quello che vorrei fare io
per andare a visitare un po il mondo ma
non si può fare perché sono segregate a
milano da due anni abbiamo fatto ragazzi
breaking the bank cavill bridgen subito
dal postino in the diamond per poi
arrivare a i filtri di dieci plus
partiamo subito le visto non si è
asciugato la faccia finalmente deciso di
spezzare ogni tipo etichette a ok mi
hanno rapito per fare un lavoro sporco
ok nell'inizio che gli aveva fatto il
fascismo e curriculum va bene è
esattamente questo il fatto come
facciamo a entrare nelle ship
si parte subito con i quattro tools
iniziale che sono questi comunque per
riassumerli deve prevedere ship è
comandato da dei cattivissimi
incredibili e visto le mie gesta
supereroiche di furto e robe del genere
hanno preso me pare per infiltrarsi va
bene lo sticky and che mi sembra la cosa
meno grave fiorato perfetto cerchiamo di
riuscire ad arrivare alla fine senza
morire mai cosa molto difficile ma ci
provo perché la partenza è stata buona
dalla ball and chain o 50 per cento
vediamo se effettivamente può avere
senso
[Musica]
grazie ciao
no come 9 dai io che me la stavo tirando
dalla serie mi piace l'ho fatta subito
ero troppo contento che siamo fatta
subito ho già vinto detto ciao finito il
video no invece no porca vacca 50 per
cento ho sbagliato ma zero point e vorrà
fare la
bene anche questa non è andata bene
allora che devo fare sono tutte e due
dove voglio allora niente tornare
indietro e hanno capito ma dimmi
sbagliato e famiglie sono tutte le
sbaglia the cal non bone the numbers
io sto qua è il capo supremo disse caso
è perfetta arrivato quando io chino su
rocket league iper nella mia porta però
tutto a posto raga sono vivo ha
funzionato sullo stemma laser cerusa
sedia perché non dovresti usare una
sedia in questo momento
ma è geniale sta roba ragazzate lo farà
anche per fare stili the diamond metti
il diamante metrò spero sono a posto
avevano capito la guerra molto più
semplice del previsto
ecco adesso mi offro da contro il boss
di turno è spikes non è servito un
cambio di niente o meno andiamo su e
jazz
va bene ben ha funzionato stavolta non
solo e sto andando ma fa niente
da mosca va bene va bene ha attivato le
forze metalist che non mi sembrata
infanti non è una moto geniale ma dovevo
farlo in fretta non ho avuto tempo di
pensare se c'era rocco non c'era manco
visione del metal fissa non so se
intendete warfare
crash bandicoot e sono in errore di
crash bandicoot sarebbe incredibile se
succedesse molti non sono mentalmente
preparati per dimensioni alternative
beni effettivamente neanche io sarei
preparato ma sarebbe comunque figo
diciamo che possiamo provare a fare
l'altro che fagioli a non l'ho applicato
in tempo bene può ora sapersi che
riflessivi nonno di 80 anni però dei
fagioli
doveva essere la mia prima scelta non so
come ho fatto non arrivarci quello come
ha fatto arrivare alla sopra robo brahms
non possono fare non possono usare
questi scusami ma questi sono da
utilizzare subito sono anche abbastanza
pratici di trovi su amazon
effettivamente sera però non so usarvi
effettivamente rockit software dovrebbe
sei carino
a serve per darti la pro funzione va beh
non è una brutta idea né buongiorno
sì ma i baffi potresti anche cambiare io
ion direi io io perché l'altro mi sono
un po troppo ovvio è una battaglia di yo
yo facciamo miike ha lasciato il gioco
non so se effettivamente dove andare
così non penso e non facciamo l'altro
marche yoyo non è solo click
ma il mini vado avanti va bene va bene
final fantasy bellissima star sono morto
avevo capito ma faccio pagare altri un
contegno a 0 che non e pozzi tools una
sega
mi sa che stavolta l'ho battuto perché
l'elevato settemila sono volute quattro
mosse però battuto meglio che lo ior pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa ra totalmente la
stessa musica perché c'era il copyright
malore da servire repliche carino soul
inglese realtà che l'intento di leggerlo
assolutamente glider assolutamente solo
questo posso vedere pervenute mi unisco
perché era troppo bello è stata la
miglior scelta finora l'ho trovato cielo
come ostaggio state lontani o mi butto
di sotto con questo qua che
effettivamente erano veramente adesso
lui mi ha dato il controllo della scip
quindi posso se non sbaglio scegliere se
tornare a scegli da che parte stare sky
fighissimo missile sto dalla parte del
cipe melo foto
perfetto dummies abbiamo buttato le
lehmann delle marionette delle dei
pupazzi con le nostre forme va bene e
adesso prendo contro le leggi è stato
abbastanza intelligente cioè non vedo
come potevate non scoprire questa cosa
mi hanno veramente promosso a capo della
hershey prima cosa c'è poteva
tranquillamente poi buttarmi di soft lui
che gli ha fregato la partenza proprio
c'è ancora no
il ps deve entrare nella legge per
prevenire questa la parte giusta aveva
meno l'abbiamo presa aspirapolvere per
aspirare la foto la penso io abbia
ispirato anche della gente ha funzionato
devo trovare qualcosa di incriminano de
va bene stanno facendo le nuove armi per
il clan
qualche idea colla no no no mi chiedete
il motivo è sì certo era chiaro
arrivarci anche la sola perché siamo
tornati qualche effetto sa da quale
invece il contrario da quando arriva
dall'altra parte ok sono sicuro fate
questo che cacchio cipat ace di sonic
devo schiacciare lui scusate perché era
troppo bello per schiacciarlo ha pure
funzionato e quello fatto kathleen gun
[Musica]
scioglimento nelle ossa scusa ma come ho
fatto
ma questo schiaccia ma cosa schiacciato
ma cosa avevo per sciogliere le ossa una
cosa e ha pure funzionato sta roba
persone in inglese
peccato ma dentro ninja star e l'ho
dovuto cliccare pure velocemente
facciamo fa con ua in cielo kick però
non è effettivamente troppa energia
troppa energia
mancava l'ultima che l'ultimo avevano
cliccato col ragno minchia stromali
avrebbe fatto caratura mary male ho
capito a sei stupido a devo entrare il
condotto c'è un problema però cosa devo
fare
il root del power fatto poi ci ho fatto
l'affetto
dove la bataille per indirizzato li
poverino come ultimo come al solito
diamo force one
certo avevo un bottone dell'orecchino mi
sembra giusto
me ne sono andato ma dove sono andato
scusa il problema ma sono caduto no 2 a
ok a posto governo forte io gli ho
consegnato totalmente il fascicolo ci
sono altre cose che non ho fatto ma ce
ne sono pochine direi che va bene che
sono molto soddisfatto orecchie del
fatto che le abbiano migliorato così
tanto perché proprio molto più bello
nei prossimi giorni ragazzi ci sarà come
euro quasi spiegato flynn the complex
ma fatemi sapere nei commenti cosa ne
pensate di infiltrati 10 bis chiede a
calare sotto un bel mi piace è una come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video meno
ragazzi
[Musica]